merci tout le monde est une grosse
délégation et que vous êtes plus qu'à
l'heure et que nous aussi on va essayer
de ne pas prendre trop de retard
puisque'à 17h nous avons Véronique
beddag qui suit cette audition et que ce
sont deux auditions qui sont aujourd'hui
extrêmement importante dans le cadre de
la mission d'information sur la crise du
logement que nous menons à la demande du
président Larcher qui a chargé
spécifiquement la commission des
affaires économiques de cette mission
d'information avec pour finalité de
rendre un rapport alors on pensait
mi-mars ça sera peut-être un peu décalé
puisque on a des auditions qu'on é amené
à décaler par voilà par multiplication
de de réunions et de travaux en même
temps pour autant on rendra donc notre
rapport à la commission des affaires
économiques au plus tard fin mars la
volonté étant que nous puissions soit
traduire tout ou partie de ce rapport
dans le casre d'une proposition de loi
donc ici au Sénat soit on avait aussi
l'imaginé intégré un certain nombre de
propositions que nous pourrions faire
dans le rapport dans le alors je sais
pas si je dois dire ex futur grand
projet de loit logement ou futur ex je
ne sais pas mais que le ministre vergrit
quand il était encore en poste nous
avait annoncé pour le mois d'avril
puisque'à chaque fois qu'on posait une
question sur les sujets du logement dans
un spectre très très large il nous
renvoyait à ce véhicule législatif euh
donc sur un calendrier qui aujourd'hui
me semble pour le moins je n'ai aucune
information mais compromis dans la
mesure où il y a même plus de ministre
délégués au logement donc on espère que
ça va arriver sous peu et donc à partir
de ce moment-là on sait pas très bien on
n' pas tellement de de vision sur euh
sur cette grande future loi logement
sachant que on est saisi donc
parallèlement à ça du projet de loi
habitat dégradé eu qui a été voté la
semaine dernière à l'assemblée qui
arrive en commission des affaires
économiques la semaine du 14 février et
en séance la semaine du 27 février et
parmi les trois rapporteurs que vous
avez devant vous c'est Amel gaaker qui a
été chargé au nom de la commission des
affaires économiques d'être rapporteur
sur ce projet de loi habitat dégradé
j'en reviens à cette mission
d'information donc le président Larchier
a souhaité qu'on se concentre vraiment
sur la crise du logement en en tant que
tel et bien évidemment bon l'état des
lieux le diagnostic grosso modo voilà on
le connaît tous mais surtout qu'on soit
force de proposition à travers des
solutions alors conjoncturelles on n'y
échara pas mais structurell et puis on
espère aussi c'est notre volonté
peut-être avec des propositions des
solutions qui soient peut-être un peu
plus innovantes que ce qu'on attend on
entend des uns et des autres ou
disruptive si on peut parler ainsi de
façon à ce que on on puisse inscrire ces
propositions dans une vision de moyen et
long terme ce qui manque cruellement à
notre politique de logement depuis un
certain nombre d'années comme on a
l'habitude de le faire au sein de la
commission des affaires économiques mais
plus généralement au sein du Sénat cette
mission on l'a conduit de façon
transpartisane je regarde le président
akadipan qu' sait bien quand on s'était
mobilisé sur Action Logement par rapport
aux misères les premières misères qu'on
qu'on qu'on voulait vous faire quand
même et qu'on avait bah Viviane était
déjà là mener cette mission
transpartisane avec Marine Noë linman
Viviane moi-même et et Valérie donc
voilà c'est des sujets que que l'on peut
porter quand même très souvent de façon
consensuelle transversal c'est ce qui
nous a amené aussi toutes les trois à
donc mener ensemble cette mission
d'information donc Amel gaker qui est
donc sénatrice du patcalé pour l'Union
centriste Vivien Artigalas que vous
connaissez qui est sénatriste socialiste
des Hautes Pyrénées et moi-même en ma
qualité de présidente de la commission
des affaires économiques et sénatrice
des Alpes Maritimes voilà en tout cas
cette présentation donc on est très très
heureuse de vous accueillir dans cette
salle pour cette audition Messieurs les
Présidents et Madame la directrice
général cher Nadia donc nous avons
commencé nos travaux à la mi à la
mi-décembre et on voudrait on a un
programme d'audition qui est très très
large bien sûr les acteurs du logement
euh Doni dans leur diversité mais aussi
on a déjà auditionné des chercheurs des
experts toute la partie aussi finance
avec la direction du Trésor enfin voilà
on essaie de balayer le spectre très
très large du secteur du logement pour
justement recueillir le maximum
d'éléments qui nous permett d'étaufer au
mieux notre rapport alors bien sûr
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de cette
audition on souhaite plus directement
aborder le sujet du lien entre l'emploi
et le logement mais ça ne nous éonère
pas de parler plus largement aussi de
cette crise du logement que vous dont
vous connaissez très certainement les
tenants et les aboutissants et en tout
cas sur lequel vous aussi vous alertez
comme nous depuis un certain nombre de
mois si ce n'est voilà d'années ou en
tout cas depuis la mandature du
président Macron 2017 mais encore plus
depuis 2022 donc nous sommes très
heureuses d'accueillir pour en parler
Monsieur Bruno arcadipan vice-président
du meddeef et président d'Action
Logement mais c'est au titre du meddeef
sauf que Bruno bon vous avez la
casquette qui est interchangeable que
vous exprimerez aujourd'hui Monsieur
François Asselin qui est président de la
CPME et Monsieur Bernard verker
président de la commission logement de
la CPME et membre à ce titre du conseil
d'administration d'Action Logement
Monsieur Philippe Langrand
vice-président d'action logementù vous
représentez la CFDT et enfin madame
Nadia Bouillet qui est la directrice
générale d'Action Logement quelques mots
d'introduction pour vous dire combien je
suis frappée du retour dans le débat
public du lien emploi logement mais
c'est vous-même qui avez porté
véritablement ce sujet dans le débat
alors qu'il y a quelques années il était
synonyme de corron et de paternalisme
pourtant et nous l'avions montré dans le
rapport du Sénat sur Action Logement où
nous avions évoqué la figure d'Albert
prouvos et l'héritage du Conseil
National de la Résistance nous sommes
convaincus que plus que jamais le lien
emploi logement est une idée éminemment
moderne c'est aussi une idée qui fait
partie de notre pacte social et de notre
culture politique du falanster de Guise
au cité castor de
ClermontFerrand à la surprise donc de
certains le patronat et les syndicats
ont pris la parole pour alerter sur le
fait qu'il n'y aurait pas de plein
emploi pas de industrialisation pas de
gain de pouvoir d'achat sans le logement
je voudrais donc que vous nous précisiez
les besoins et les difficultés
rencontrées Patrick Martin président du
medf a pu indiquer qu'un chômeur sur
deux renonce à un emploi s'il doit
déménager ou la CPME qu'un recrutement
sur 5 ne se ferait pas faute de logement
je souhaite également que vous nous
présentiez les réponses actuellement
déjà mis en œuvre leurs résultats mais
aussi peut-être leurs limites tant pour
les saisonniers pour les jeunes et dans
le cadre des grands chantiers comment
peut-on les faciliter enfin quelles sont
vos propositions pour aller plus loin
que faut-il changer ou faut-il des
moyens quelles ressources faut-il
mobiliser cela passe-t-il par plus de
logements sociaux plus de logements
intermédiaires plus de logements
accession à la propriété je dire dirit
les
trois très certainement alors je vous
l'ai dit nous envisageons donc de
déposer une proposition de loi ou des
amendements dans ce projet de lo
logement s'il voit un jour le jour avant
de vous laisser la parole pour une
quinzaine de minutes pour chaque entité
puis que nous échangions je vous indique
que notre audition fait l'objet d'une
retransmission en vidéo en direct et à
la demande sur le site internet du Sénat
et sur les réseaux sociaux voilà je vais
vous laisser la parole euh vous vous la
distribuez comme vous l'entendez on a
jusqu'à 17h ce qui nous laisse quand
même une belle plage horaire pour
échanger avec vous et ensuite une fois
que vous nous aurez déjà dressé ce
premier tableau bien évidemment les unes
et les autres ne manqueront pas de vous
poser d'autres questions complémentaires
merci je laisse la parole au au
président d'Action
Logement merci merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Mesdames les
sénatrices comme vous l'avez dit je vais
essayer d'interchanger mes casquettes
pour à la fois représenter le le MDEF et
et son président Patrick Martin et puis
la la présidence également d'Action
Logement peut-être quelques mots de
remise en
contexte de de la situation que
d'ailleurs vous avez décrite avec
beaucoup déjà de de précision mais
peut-être pour rappeler qu'en effet
depuis 2017
on se bagarre ensemble je crois qu'on
peut le dire de de cette façonl pour
lancer un un cri d'alerte pour le
logement le logement abordable et puis
pour nos filières notamment de la
construction et et filière connexe qui
évidemment dépendent
de de de tout ce secteur
euh je crois que si on prend que la
partie logement logement social logement
abordable ce sont plus de 10 milliards
d'euros de de perdu pour pour le
secteur et c'est donc évidemment
aujourd'hui avec beaucoup de de de
tristesse mais de réalisme qu'on regarde
les résultats de de cette politique qui
est
menée depuis depuis cette
période alors la RLS c'est
2018 la RLS c'est un TR par an donc il
suffit de de faire la multiplication
pour voir que c'est déjà un très gros
bout de de ces 10 milliards d'euros mais
pas que les ponctions qu'on subit enfin
qu'a subit le le groupe Action Logement
on font également
partie l'ensemble des des
réductions par petit bout de l'ensemble
de de nos
facilité financière sur le secteur du
logement social ont impacté
cette capacité d'intervention que
l'ensemble des bailleurs publics comme
privés pouvait avoir sur sur notre pays
ensuite sont venus s'ajouter à ça les
problématiques des différentes crises
que l'on a essuyé l'augmentation du livr
à l'inflation les différents
conflits européens et mondiaux qui font
que tous ces coûts n'ont cessé d'être
les coûts de la construction n'ont cessé
de d'être Sanch
et euh et et au final on arrive à une
situation 2023 qui est totalement
calamiteuse avec à peine
82000 agréments donc ce que nous avions
prédit malheureusement est arrivé là on
parle plus au futur nous sommes dedans
et on commence à le voir de façon très
brutale à à travers les grandes
difficultés
que beaucoup de professions commencent à
rencontrer évidemment celle de la
filière construction évidemment celle du
des travaux publics
puisque lorsqu'on rénove ou lorsqu'on
construit des des immeubles neufs on
fait du parking on on fait tout un tas
de de travaux qui qui dépendent du des
travaux publics mais pas que les
notaires sont hyper
impactés tous les gens qui travaillaient
sur la numérisation de ces professions
euh sont aujourd'hui à l'arrêt parce que
quand on a des difficultés euh
financière évidemment les premiers trucs
que l'on coupe c'est le développement
c'est euh c'est les investissements
lourds et et tout ça est en train de
créer un un malaise que nous avions
deviné dessiné mais qui aujourd'hui sont
vraiment euh enfin nous nous nous frappe
vraiment avec une très grande brutalité
donc on a eu tout un tas de d'occasions
de
discuter le CNR étant je pense le SOMUM
euh de de l'inefficacité il faut appeler
un chat un chat et je laisserai
Véronique Bedag à partir de 17h vous
dire ce qu'elle en pense puisqu'elle l'a
vécu au au au
premier au premier rang mais pour des
acteurs comme nous que ce soit euh
avec notre casquette patronale ou avec
la casquette de de de président d'Action
Logement c'est très difficile à vivre
lorsque vous recevez en
permanence des dizaines de demande
chaque jour de logement de la part de
nos concitoyens et tout particulièrement
de
salariés du secteur privé et pas que
aujourd'hui ça ça touche aussi le
secteur public ça touche l'ensemble des
secteurs tous ces gens que que l'on
applaudissait à
20h tous ces gens qu' que l'ont
monté en gloire durant plus d'un an et
demi aujourd'hui on sait pas les loger
c'est les mêmes c'est les mêmes
lorsqu'une une infirmière du privé vient
me voir et me dit je peux plus j'en peux
plus euh je suis trop loin j'interviens
trop tard et cetera et cetera c'est ce
sont des euh des des choses qui sont
insupportable quand on voit des
reportages ou pire encore des gens qui
viennent vous trouver à la sortie d'un
événement qui vous disent ben voilà j'ai
un CDI je travaille chez Intel et je
dors dans ma
voiture c'est plus possible donc
aujourd'hui en effet il faut trouver des
solutions je crois que et le MF et la et
la CPME et d'autres encore ont des
propositions concrètes factuelles
efficaces mais il nous faut
surtout une volonté politique de faire
et la
problématique la plus importante elle
est là est-ce que l'on doit continuer à
loger nos concitoyens la réponse semble
évidente mais euh j'ai quand même de
grandes inquiétudes sur sur le résultat
il faut il faut dire les choses et en
tout cas moi je je suis venu devant vous
aujourd'hui pour vous dire les choses
avec beaucoup de de clarté et et et une
volonté ferme de
faire mais on peut pas le réaliser tout
seul il nous faut évidemment le Terrero
alors j'entends par ici ou par là le BRS
le truc oui oui mais c'est pas avec ça
qu'on va loger
330000 personnes qui dorment dans la rue
r femme enfant et et et
salariés et c'est pas avec ça qu'on va
rel reloger
confortablement plus de 4 millions de
personnes m logées sur le
territoire donc évidemment il faudra de
la
simplification évidemment il faudra tout
un tas de choses que l'on est tous
enclin à à valider et cetera mais il
faudra beaucoup plus si on veut
affronter les sujets droit dans les yeux
il va falloir prendre des décisions
fermes il faut arrêter d'imaginer qu'à
chaque fois que l'on prend une décision
pour
donner l'envie de faire on dit oui mais
c'est des avantages fiscaux c'est du
dopage fiscal enfin on a entendu quand
même des propos ultra violent et de tous
les
côtés donc au niveau du Medef pour être
très clair on est dans une volonté
absolue
d'aider l'ensemble de de du secteur de
la construction et du logement
abordable sans aller jusque là aussi
quelques aberrations que l'on a pu
entendre même à l'Assemblée nationale du
type on va
relier le contrat de travail au bail
voilà ça c'est des choses qui pour nous
sont impossibles on va pas revenir 70
ans ou 80 ans en arrière les entreprises
vont pas se mettre à construire les unes
derrière les autres deux logements trois
logements on voit bien les résultats sur
les quelques résidences qui ont été
réalisé par quelques belles entreprises
françaises pourtant même du C 40 et
cetera et aujourd'hui on voit bien que
le résultat il est plutôt dans la
mauvaise gestion ou le
malentretien et cetera et cetera je
crois que qu'il faut être sérieux c'est
un métier sérieux de loger nos
concitoyens c'est un un sujet d'expert
et de professionnel et qu'il est
important que
euh au cours de de cette audition on
puisse à la fois vous proposer des
choses concrètes qu'on pourra mettre de
toute façon à votre disposition par
écrit comme on le fait de façon très
régulière mais aussi qu'on se dise des
choses cette volonté de faire elle ne
peut venir que de votre part de la part
des des élus de la part de l'exécutif de
de la part de ceux qui tout en haut vont
insuffler euh les décisions et surtout
nous apporter ce terreau pour faire
alors on est tous d'accord hein le le le
foncier est trop cher il
faut peut-être l'encadrer ou pas et
cetera on va y revenir point par point
mais la chose dont on ne peut pas euh
discuter
c'est
l'accélération du mallogement de nos
concitoyens depuis 2017 je rappelle
c'est toujours important de le dire 2017
fichier SNE donc des demandeurs de
logements sociaux 1700000 personnes à
l'heure où on se parle plus de
2liion4 voilà où nous mène une politique
de non production et là aussi je veux
dans le propos productif dire tout de
suite que on ne peut pas opposer
réhabilitation et
construction parce que les deux sont
impératif évidemment dans ce que vous
disiez tout à
l'heure tout est juste il faut produire
il
faut également réhabiliter donc
décarboner mais il faut aussi produire
pour donner de l'accession à la
propriété notamment au au primau
accédant donc c'est tout ça ça que l'on
doit
faire dans une
période j'ose pas dire en même temps
mais en tout cas sur une période
extrêmement courte on doit être capable
de baisser les taux au moins pour les
primau accédent on doit être capable de
redonner l'envie au Mair de
bâtir en donnant peut-être une écaille
de la TVA enfin là aussi on peut revenir
dans le détail sur sur nos
propositions et on doit aussi arrêter au
moins pour la période d'inflation et de
taux du livréat très élevé arrêter la
RLS 1
mliard3 prix aux bailleurs sociaux enfin
à un moment
donné quel est le secteur
d'activité qui lorsque tous les vecteurs
sont au rouge ne bénéficie
d'aucune d'aucune aide donc j'entends
Bruno Le Maire dire qu'il nous
entend même le chef de l'État reconnu
qu'il avait une crise du logement dans
sa conférence de presse de 2h3 ok mais
on fait quoi aujourd'hui on fait quoi et
ce métier ne fonctionne qu'à coup de
fond propre à enfin tous les
bailleurs si demain ils prennent
vraiment peur si on leur donne pas un
peu de vision de de visibilité et de
stabilité demain matin si tout le monde
lève les fourches ça va être très très
compliqué ça va être compliqué demain
matin mais aussi après après-demain
parce que relancer la mécanique sur ces
secteurs là on le sait tous ça prend des
années voilà ce que je voulais dire sur
le propos introductif merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente Mesdames
les sénatrices merci pour cette audition
euh quelques éléments contextuels je su
pas je suis bien évidemment 100 %
d'accord avec ce que vient d'exprimer
Bruno et ce que tu dis tout à fait juste
c'estd que même si aujourd'hui on prend
des mesures énergiques le secteur de la
construction est un secteur avec une
très forte inertie ça veut dire que 2024
est une année déjà voilà noire 2023
était grise donc ça veut dire que quel
que soit les décisions même énergiques
que l'on puisse prendre aujourd'hui ou
dans les semaines qui viennent et bien
on a encore de de voilà un mauvais
passage devant nous finalement on répond
à un besoin essentiel de l'être humain
se nourrir se loger c'est les premier
élément dans la pé de Melow et pour moi
c'est un vrai mystère parce que ça fait
des mois des années où on dit B écoutez
voilà la catastrophe va arriver et et
elle est là et on a l'impression
effectivement qu' une du côté on va dire
exécutif une forte
inertie avec une affirmation qu'on peut
comprendre le logement est trop cher ok
difficile d'accéder un logement trop
cher mais en attendant il y a pas de
bulle immobilière c'est-à-dire que
l'offre se rétrécit et la demande
augmente donc je ne vois pas comment
dans les années qui viennent le logement
sera moins cher puisque bien si on
regarde l'évolution du marché c'est une
tension à laquelle il va falloir encore
s'attendre dans les mois et les années
qui viennent alors face à ce
constat qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire vous
avez différents segments de marché vous
l'avez très bien dit madame la
Présidente le les primos accédent vous
avez ceux qui ont de l'épargne et qui
n'investissent plus dans le logement
pour des raisons qu'on connaît tous hein
euh l'IFI a été un signal on va dire
voilà clair hein sur le fait qu'investir
dans l'immobilier ben finalement ne
nourrissait pas l'économie he
intrinsèquement c'est un petit peu ce
qui voilà alors qu'on ne pense pas
derrière qu'il y a des entreprises qui
construisent qu'il y a des notaires qui
ont des droits de mutation qu'il y a des
départements des collectivité qui au
passage aussi et bien sont financés bref
qu'il y a des travaux d'entretien tout
ce qu'on connaî autour de de l'économie
de la construction la rénovation ensuite
on a cette transition
écologique le DPE en soi est une bonne
idée pourquoi parce que c'est un outil
qui calibre le marché hein effectivement
donner une prime aux bâtiments on va
dire qui sont plus performant que
d'autres en matière énergétique et pas
idiot mais mettre en plus des mesures
coercitives ben là ça ne va pas pourquoi
parce que nous ce qui est remontait à la
CPM il y a déjà 2 ans ce sont des
anciens artisans des anciens commerçants
pour qui le seul complé de retraite et
Dieu sait qu'ils ont une petite retraite
c'est l'appartement dans lequel ils ont
investi il y a peut-être 10 ou 20 ans et
qui bien évidemment est mal classé ils
ont 75 ans 80 ans ils n'ont pas les
moyens de faire les travaux et quand
bien même on leur donne entre guillemets
une grande part de prime pour faire les
travaux le reste à charge est parfois
inaccessible pour ces petits retraités
et bien il se retrouent dépossédés et
plus on avance dans le temps et bien
plus on sort en plus du marché locative
des logements qui sont classés par pass
thermique mais qui ne sont pas tous des
logements insalubres il faut pas
mélanger les deux voyez hein donc
maintenant qu'on a le constat qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire alors vous avez
souligné effectivement quelque chose qui
nous tient à cœur nous chez l'entreprise
c'est tout ce qui concerne la
mobilité voilà alors pourquoi pas par
exemple déduire les intérêts d'emprunt
pour les accédentss en mobilité
professionnelle quand ils acquierèrent
un logement pourquoi pas instaurer un
crédit d'impôt pour les frais de
déménagement pourquoi pas garantir enfin
en tout cas garantir le dispositif visal
hein l' caution gratuite proposé par
Action Logement pourquoi pas remplacer
le dépôt de garantie par un système
assuranciel imaginez de supprimer les
premières tranches d'impôt sur le revenu
en cas de mobilité professionnelle ou
encore instaurer un crédit relais
souvent lorsqu'il s'agit de vendre un
logement pour un acquérir un autre à
taux réseau à taux zéro pardon pour la
revente de la résidence principale hein
voilà quelques idées très concrètes
qu'on pourrait imaginer sur la mobilité
sur l'acquisition il y a une chose qui
avait très bien fonctionné parce que
vous avez les primos accédents et vous
avez une grosse partie du marché qui est
réservée à ceux qui ont de l'épargne
faut pas se mentir faut avoir de
l'argent pour acheter dans l'immobilier
et cette épargne aujourd'hui est bloquée
dans toute autre chose sauf dans
l'immobilier he une chose qui très bien
fonctionn c'est la déduction des
intérêts d'emprunt voilà alors quand on
a une annonce de baisse des taux qui va
finir par arriver vous avez un potentiel
effet de levier qui est considérable
maintenant bien évidemment nous sommes
tous attentifs aujourd'hui aux finances
de l'État mais je crois qu'on arrive à
un moment où faut vraiment faire la
balance des choses regardez ce que
génère l'acte de construction en matière
de génération de TVA mine de rien hein
je parlais des droits de mutation mais
derrière vous avez des entreprises qui
vont travailler qui vont payer des
salariés donc qui vont payer aussi des
impôts des taxes qui vont nourrir bien
évidemment à travers les charges les
différentes caisses et le système social
de notre pays bref c un secteur non
délocalisable voilà donc c'est-à-dire
que l'argent investi en France retourne
aux entreprises françaises et aux
Français qui sont employés dans ces
entreprises françaises et vous avez ici
un excellent document qui a été édité la
semaine dernière par l'Alliance logement
où la FB avec tous ses partenaires
l'UNIS l'Intec l'fnaim et bien d'autres
et bien se sont finalement réunis pour
dire écoutez voilà les chif voilà le
constat et maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on
fait ben écoutez je crois
qu'effectivement on est maintenant euh
euh dans l'urgence de poser des actes
forts pour relancer euh la construction
pour les Primot accédants euh il y avait
autrefois des prêts bonifiés c'est
finalement ni plus ni moins le le prêt à
tau zéro on sait que ça fonctionne voilà
alors évidemment là encore on va tout le
temps vous dire mais regardez les
finances de l'État mais où vont loger
nos concitoyens demain voilà et déjà dès
aujourd'hui voilà donc ce sont
finalement des choses qui ont déjà
existé qui ont fait leur preuve on
peut-être effectivement un peu plus
imaginatif un peu plus créatif sur tout
ce qui concerne la mobilité parce que là
effectivement il y a pas grand-chose on
peut bien dire les choses et puis sur
tout l'aspect réglementaire accélérer
les procédures ben écoutez on a en
préparation une magnifique j'espère loi
sur la simplification la fameusect 2
c'est peut-être l'occasion de pousser le
curseur jusqu il faut pour que enfin
accélérer l'acte de construire ou de
rénover
je pique le micro du président ça
commence
bienon il y a beaucoup de complicit
entre nous voilà vous l'avez vous l'avez
vous l'avez
compris non mais je tenais déjà dans un
premier temps à vous remercier le
président l'a fait mais je vais faire
aussi vous remercier de de cette
invitation et on sait que les sénateurs
sont très attachés à ce à ce sujet et
que vous avez joué un rôle important
dans on peut dire le moment difficile
qu'à traversé Action Logement dans le
cadre de sa négociation sur la nouvelle
convention
quinquenal bien alors je suis
vice-président d'Action Logement et et
aussi et aussi CFDT j'ai été d'ailleurs
membre du bureau national de la CFDT
pendant très longtemps mais ceci dit je
partage bon nombre des des des des des
propos qui ont été tenus par à la fois
enfin par les par les deux
précédentes les deux précédentes
interventions
le constat je vais être assez rapide sur
le constat puisque je pense qu'on le
partage tous et qu'on le et qu'on le
connaît ceci dit quand même je crois
pouvoir dire
que les besoins en logement abordable
sont très très forts alors est-ce que ce
son plus fort qu'un connu notre histoire
sans doute pas mais en tout cas ils sont
particulièrement forts et ce depuis 30
une trentaine une trentaine d'années ils
sont particulièrement forts notamment
pour les jeunes ce qu'il faut avoir en
tête c'est qu'on crée aussi par là une
fracture générationnelle qui ne sera pas
sans conséquence des jeunes qui déjà
connaissent des disparités dans le monde
du travail on sait très bien que les
jeunes sont plus de contrat à durée
déterminée que les moins jeunes
qu'eectivement le nombre de contratsurin
indéterminés est encore largement
majoritaire dans ce pays mais que les
jeunes qui rentrent sur le marché du
travail majoritairement ont des contrats
à durée déterminé donc si on y ajoute la
question du logement plus d'autres autre
sujet on voit qu'on est sur une fracture
générationnelle qui peut avoir des
conséquences lourdes sur nos systèmes
collectifs sur nos systèmes de
protection sociale et sur no et sur
l'intérêt général de façon de façon
globale donc il faut l'avoir en tête
aussi le poids du logement est
particulièrement fort aussi c'est
environ un/ers des dépenses contraintes
d'un ménage aujourd'hui parfois plus
notamment sur une région comme
l'île-de-fance ou d'autres régions ce
qui d'as d'ailleurs joue un un r je vais
faire un lien avec l'actualité on parle
beaucoup d'agriculture ces derniers
jours ces dernières semaines ben quand
on met un/ers de ces dépenses
contraintes dans le logement c'est sûr
qu'on fait attention au reste et le
reste c'est l'alimentation par exemple
bon
euh et puis je pense au travailleurs
pauvres aux travailleurs précaires Bruno
d'ailleurs l'a dit de façon extrêmement
forte à l'instant euh les travailleurs
de première et de deuxème ligne qu'on le
les a appelé qui ont du mal à accéder au
logement et donc à l'emploi hein et des
employés
aussi qui de fait ont du mal à trouver
des des salariés tout ça engendre des
difficultés sociales économiques et moi
j'ajouterai démocratique à moyen ou long
terme ça peut être une future bombe ça
aussi alors là on a les questions
agricoles aujourd'hui mais peut-être que
demain on aura ces questions là qui
viendront sur le sur le devant de la
scène et on dira tiens c'est vrai qu'on
n pas traité ces questions
alors bah Action Logement là je moi
aussi à l'instar de de de Bruno j'ai un
peu de casquette la casquette CFDT et la
casquette de vice-président de l'action
logement mais action Action Logement il
a traversé une tempête que vous
connaissez il traverse une autre une
autre tempête une tempête plus générale
bon qui est la crise la crise du
logement pourquoi je dis ça parce que
euh les salariés qu'on représente bah
ils se
tournent principalement lorsqu'ils ont
une demande de logement vers Action
Logement l'ancien 1 % logement voilà
donc nos demandes sont extrêmement
fortes
et j'ai envie de dire que même si les
résultats sont là bon vous les
connaissez on vous les communiquera
peut-être que j'en dirai un mot mais les
résultats d'Action Logement sur 2023
sont sont sont bons mais ceci dit ils
ont beau être bons les demandes sont
sont tellement fortes que bon nombre de
salariés se disent mais qu'est-ce qui se
passe comment se fait-il que j'ai pas de
réponse à à à à mes demandes et
pourtant on fait un/ers de de la
production de logement alors qu'on
représente 18 % du du parc à la fois
sociale et et intermédiaire et pourtant
on a un peu plus d'un million
100000 100000
logements j'ajoute que si on y loge les
salariés vous voyez bien que j'insiste
beaucoup sur cette question là depuis
tout à l'heure et c'est bien légitime on
loge aussi des publics prioritaires les
Dallos et cetera aussi donc on a aussi
un rôle d'intérêt général qu'il faut
qu'il faut souligner
alors pour ce qui nous concerne
maintenant on s'inscrit dans la dans la
convtion sur kakenal qui a été négocié
et signé en en juin dernier avec la
première ministre ce qui nous permet
d'avoir une certaine sérénité sur les
sur les mois et les années qui viennent
de se projeter hein dans ce monde bien
bien complexe du du logement sur en 2024
puque
2023 je pense que vous connaissez les
résultats et de toute façon on vous les
communiquera je vais pas trop insister
là-dessus même si on a été au
rendez-vous à la fois en terme de
construction de rénovation et aussi
d'aide et de service au salariés je je
rappelle quand même que c'est 750000
aides et services qui ont été octroyés
aux salariés sur l'année 2023 la grosse
partie bien évidemment c'est visale à
peu près la moitié la moitié des aides
mais il y a beaucoup d'aide monsieur
aselin parlait beaucoup de de de de
mobilité professionnelle il y a beaucoup
d'aide en matière de mobilité euh par
exemple alors sur 2024 bien sûr la
mobilisation à l'adresse des salariés et
de l'accompagnement sera au rendez-vous
de même qu'on continuera à voir nos
trois axes nos 3 x 40 comme on le dit
parfois car 00 solution logement pour
les salariés 40000 m en chantier et
40000 réhabilitation donc on est au
rendez-vous est-ce que c'est suffisant
bien sû que non on voit bien que la
crise est tellement grave que ce que
peut faire ce que pe conduire àtion
logement n'est pas n'est pas suffisant
alors j' une fois que j'ai dit tout
ça qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire évidment
je partage qui dit précédemment là
encore mais j'ajouterai de ou TR
choses moi il me semble qu'avant d'aller
vers des mesures concrètes et il peut y
avoir plein il faut déjà qu'on partage
le diagnostic parce que ce qu'on vient
de se dire là moi je suis pas sûr que ce
soit partagé par tout le monde loin sans
faut or si on partage pas le diagnostic
bah on peut toujours mettre 50 100
propositions
elles sont pas retenu parce que certains
diront il y a pas besoin de logement
vous êtes en train de nous raconter des
histoires voilà où il y a pas besoin de
réhabilitation de réhabiliter pardon le
parc comme comme vous pensez le faire
comme vous souhaitez le faire donc là
c'est un nœud énorme parce que alors on
est partenaires sociaux on a l'habitude
de de négocier sur bon nombre de sujets
si entre nous déjà on partage pas
diagnostic on pe on peut repartir
onancera pas donc il faut que le le
diagnostic soit partagé est-ce qu'il
faut plus de logement moi je pense que
oui la CFDT pense que oui et Action
Logement pense que oui il faut plus de
logement et pour répondre à votre
question initiale il faut du logement
social il faut du logement social parce
que là
aussi déjà plus de logement certains ne
sont pas forcément d'accord mais si on
dit plus de logement social il y en a
encore moins bon pour différentes
raisons bon mais il faut du logement
social pourquoi parce que on a un
certain nombre de travailleurs pauvres
qui ne peuvent se loger que dans du
logement social et si on veut répondre
aussi à la question de la mixité sociale
il faut mixer les populations ça veut
dire que il faut pas transformer le
longement social en une espèce de ghetto
je n'aime pas je n'aime pas ce terme
mais on retrouverait que des gens en
extrême difficulté donc il faut qu'on
soit en capacité de loger des
travailleurs des travailleurs avec des
revenus faible le nombre de smicar il
est important donc ils ont une place
dans le dans dans dans le logement
social il faut du logement intermédiaire
je pense qu'il faut pas opposer l'un au
l'autre comme certains le font et puis
il faut relancer l'accession à la
propriété ça me paraît essentiel là
aussi on
a on a un pied sur le frein extrêmement
fort sur sur l'accession à la propriété
donc on voit que tout est bloqué en fait
le le le système est le système est
bloqué avant d'arriver aux propositions
concrètes moi je moi je pense aussi que
au-delà de partager le diagnostic il
faut que le travail soit plus horizontal
c'est-à-dire que alors c'est un peu ce
que vous faites d'ailleurs là vous allez
auditionner l'état d'acteur mais je
pense que on a besoin d'horizontalité
sur cette question
là on a besoin aussi de d'éviter les
oppositions or moi ce que je constate
depuis un certain nombre de moi depuis
qu'on parle de crise de logement c'est
qu'on il y a beaucoup d'opposition alors
il y aurait ceux qui sont en location et
qui je dis comme je le pense mais être
en location à 50 ans ça veut dire qu'on
a pas réussi son parcours professionnel
voire même sa vie bah ça ça pose un
problème d'entendre ça voilà mais il y a
aussi le contraire c'est-à-dire on
stigmatise aussi celui qui est
propriétaire et celui qui va proposer
aussi un
logementard voilà par exemple mais celui
qui va proposer à loocation or là aussi
si on oppose les les les uns aux autres
ben ceux qui ont un peu de patrimoine
ben ils vont je le dis hein ils vont le
mettre en assurance vie ils vont pas le
mettre dans l'immobilier c'est déjà un
peu ce qui se passe bon donc il faut pas
opposer aussi les or on a tendance à le
faire euh je sais pas si c'est dur en
même temps mais ça c'est je dirais pas
ça c'est plutôt de l'opposition voilà
alors après il y a les fausses bonnes
solutions que je partage aussi hein
Bruno a parlé du du lien contrat de
travail et et et et du bail je reviens
pas là-dessus mais on avait été
auditionné à plusieurs reprises sur ces
questionsl et et on a montré notre notre
opposition sur sur cette fausse bonne
idée comme j'ai eu l'occasion de de de
de le dire voilà se rajoute à tout à
tout ce que je viens de dire les
questions
climatiques qui ont une importance
considérable aujourd'hui et encore plus
demain euh le vieillissement de la
population ça aussi il faut l'avoir en
tête même si j'ai beaucoup parlé des
jeunes on a quand même un vieillissement
de la population qui va jouer énormément
sur
l'immobilier et
puis là aussi je rejoins les propos de
de Bruno c'est-à-dire comment comment on
aide les maires demain face à face à cet
enjeu énorme et puis et puis la RLS je
finirai là-dessus mais là je pense qu'il
faut revenir sur sur sur ce dispositif
parce qu'on a des des bailleurs qui sont
pris qui sont pris à la gorge voilà et
puis il faudra aussi
alors il y a d'autres sujets aussi je
rentre un peu dans détail
mais quand on parle des salariés le
monde du travail est profondément
bouleversé il change
beaucoup il y a des questions nouvelles
qui se posent en tout cas qui ont
tendance à à s'accentuer je pense au
saisonniers par exemple donc ce sont des
questions quand même nouvelle qui se
pose à nous et là aussi faudraut faut
qu'on soit en capacité d'y
répondre monsieur Berker est-ce que vous
souhaitez prendre la
parole merci madame la Présidente
mesdames les sénatrices je voudrais
revenir sur sur deux points que je
trouve effectivement très importants
dans nos dans nos échange je vlais
rajouter aussi que je suis
administrateur de lanrue et de koalia ce
qui effectivement à son importance dans
l'analyse qu'on peut
avoir on a parlé beaucoup de mixité
sociale dans les quartiers dans les
qpv où j'ai mes magasins je suis au
conta direct avec la population qui est
dans ces quartiers si on veut
réussir il y a pas 36 solution il y a la
construction comme on l'a dit et la
réhabilitation en ciblant très
clairement ce qu'on veut
faire qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire alors
c'est vrai c'est joli de mettre un
balcon de repeindre les murs extérieurs
et
compag mais la
sécurité en premier si vous voulez
réussir la mixité sociale dans ces
quartiers la première des choses à faire
c'est la sécurité je sais bien que c'est
pas le lieu pour le dire mais je crois
que ça fait partie importante de
l'analyse qu'on doit avoir
là-dessus les deux volets que je voulais
mettre en avant moi je dis je sépare les
choses en deux il y a le volet location
et le volet
propriétaire le volet
location je crois qu'on a cassé le CIRC
vertueux qui était primo acccédent
ensuite qui libérait
évidemment un logement qui permettait
bien entendu à d'autres
d'arriver il y a la famille qui
s'agrandit et ça aussi faut pas
l'oublier si vous on a fait je crois pas
mal de reportages ces dernières semaines
sur le fait que les Françaises faisaient
moins de d'enfants
qu'avant je sais pas s'il y a une
relation directe avec le logement ou non
je m'en garderai bien mais si vous
agrandissez la famille vous devez
agrandir votre logement donc là vous
montez une
étape et
puis si vos moyens si vos moyens
financiers le permettent à un moment
donné vous achetez et ça libère à
nouveau donc ce cercle vertueux que nous
avions mis en place depuis des des
décennies est aujour le parcours
résidentiel le parcours R est totalement
à l'arrêt aujourd'hui et il faut casser
effectivement
ceut faut remettre en route je dirais ce
ce parcours résidentiel ça me paraît et
ça me paraît
évident un sujet qui a pas été abordé je
crois ou s'il a été abordé rapidement le
Airbnb ça fait partie aussi du fait
qu'on a moins de bien aujourd'hui en
location sur le marché parce que que
faut dire les choses très clairement
c'est plus flexible c'est moins taxé et
ça rapporte
plus donc là aussi il y a peut-être il y
a pas l'obligation de travaux il y a pas
l'obligation de
travauxcoup non non mais c'est c'est
tout à fait ça donc il y a d'énormes
avantages aujourd'hui à ne pas être
entre guillemets lorsqu'on est
propriétaire prisonnier d'un bail et de
pouvoir
effectivement je dirais gagner
confondablement sa vie je dirais en
travaillant sur ce sujet et je pense que
la région parisienne ou Paris plutôt est
très en avant sur le sujet et ça le
provincial que je suis irait pas sur ce
dernière chose le volet propriétaire et
là mon président l'a très bien dit
aujourd'hui les
adhérents que je représente sont
extrêmement
inquiets pardon excuse-moi tu as dit mon
président mais président parce qu' il
est aussi mon président
l' très bien dit c'est vrai que le fait
d'être interdit à la location en 2025
pour les passoir thermiques
alors François l'a dit tout à l'heure
passoir thermique c'est un grand mot qui
englobe beaucoup de choses et pas
forcément systématiquement je crois
qu'il va falloir retravailler et
notamment à travers le DPE une
l'ification je dirais de ce DPE est à
mon avis obligatoire pour bien séparer
les choses pour bien analyser les choses
et dernière les taux d'emprunt et là
François l'a encore dit tout à l'heure
les TR t deemprunt aujourd'hui sont le
frein ultime pourquoi ne pas revenir au
reste à
vivre pourquoi ce taux de
30 33 34 on pourrait considérer le
d'abord le patrimoine du foyer déjà ou
de la de de du futur propriétaire ou du
primo acccédent he voilà plutôt que
simplement la partie revenue déjà
élargir donc voilà c'était un peu le le
le constat et puis quelques pistes de je
de travail
futur merci Monsieur portelier est-ce
que vous souhaitez intervenir pas pour
l'instant madame Bouillet Madame la
Directrice merci madame la Présidente
bonjour à toutes merci beaucoup pour
pour cette invitation beaucoup de choses
ont été dites peut-être je vais prendre
un peu plus la casquette Action Logement
et rappeler un certain nombre de de
mesures qu'on a pu prendre dans ce
contexte mais juste en amont et je pense
que votre mission déjà elle est très
très importante actuellement et ce qu'on
entend des différents témoignages mais
ce que vous avez pu voir je pense aussi
dans vos auditions c'est qu'on est là
dans une crise qui est structurelle et
donc faut pas se laisser enfermer dans
le fait que c'est juste conjoncturel euh
en fait c'est les germes de la crise on
les a depuis longtemps euh on le sait et
effectivement le l'augmentation des taux
d'emprunt a été un révélateur mais on
n'est pas face à un simple problème
conjoncturel et donc merci beaucoup de
voilà de de cette mission d'information
qui est mon avis va permettre d'éclairer
ça donc nous Action Logement on est un
un opérateur un acteur et donc
effectivement on n'agit pas en tant que
régulateur mais on s'adapte par rapport
aux contraintes de marché pour trouver
systématiquement les les meilleures solu
et quand elles existent pas les inventer
une bonne solution ça a été d'inventer
visal par exemple qui effectivement lié
ben au fonctionnement de notre marché
locatif qui exclué beaucoup de jeunes
donc on a créé cette garantie pour les
jeunes 320000 en 2023 donc on est en
augmentation constante depuis 2016 on
était à 200 moins de 290000 en 2022 et
cette année on devrait avoir 376000
personnes qui vont accé céder au parc
privé grâce à cette caution visale donc
ça c'est vrai que c'est ce type de de
mesure qu'on a pu prendre on a pris des
mesures après la pendant la crise
sanitaire et juste après d'aide
notamment pour les salariés qui auraient
pu se retrouver en difficulté donc
c'était des aides pour financer une part
voilà du du loyer ou de charge d'emprunt
qui a permis de d'accompagner plus de
100000 110000 ménages on a aidé les
opérateurs à la reprise des chantiers
aussi avec des des enveloppes
spécifiques de prêt de redémarrage de de
chantier donc ça a été fait et puis en
2023 il y a deux mesures qui ont été
prises la première c'est cet été de
baisser notre taux d'emprunt qu'on avait
un peu monté suite à l'augmentation des
taux il était à 1,5 on l'a ramené à 1 %
le prêt le prêt patronal enfin c'est un
prêtaccession de 30000 € et ça a permis
d'accompagner
18000 ménages dans leur projet
d'accession à la propriété en 2023 et ce
ce qu'on voit au niveau enfin qualitatif
un peu notre ressenti c'est que c'est
vrai
que ce prêt il a pu faire débat même
dans les discussions de la convention
quinquenal en nous disant mais pourquoi
vous faites des prêts tant que les taux
étaient très bas c'est vrai que notre
prêt avec un taux très bas il avait pas
forcément un intérêt mais là ce qu'on a
vu surt le deuxème semestre c'est des
banques qui attendaient que on débloque
le prêt pour pouvoir donner le prêt à
des primos accédents donc c'est vrai que
c'est là c'est encore plus important
d'avoir ce taux à 1 % et donc ça renvoie
aussi à un l'importance qu'on peut avoir
du PTZ qui qui est complémentaire he et
bien sûr nous ça se cumule donc ça
c'était une mesure et l'autre mesure
qu'on a prise j'allais dire c'était une
mesure assumée par les partenaires
sociaux de dépassement de l'enveloppe
c'est-à-dire que même si on avait
dépassé l'enveloppe contractualisée dans
le quinquenal on a distribué 181 million
d'euros de plus que ce qui était prévu
parce que justement il y avait une vraie
demande derrière et que il nous semblait
impensable de rajouter ajouter de la
crise à la crise en en nous refusant ces
ces emprunts deuxième mesure qui a pu
être prise bah dès le la signature de la
convention quinquenal et donc qui est
très structurante c'est le plan 30000
logements pour l'emploi un plan de
rachat de logements au aux promoteurs en
fait qui qui a vraiment comme vocation
de loger des salariés puisque sinon ces
logements ne sortaient pas et donc
c'était une offre de moins pour les
salariés euh ça on a pu le lancer au
mois de juin puisque la convention a été
signée le 16 juin on pouvait pas le
faire avant d'où l'importance aussi
d'avoir réussi à avoir cet accord global
sur la convention quinquenal et les les
résultats de ce plan qui est aujourd'hui
terminé puisqu'on a atteint notre
objectif c'est quand même plus de 110000
logements qui ont été proposés par les
par les promoteurs on a mis en place un
système très agile avec dans les 15
jours un interlocuteur qui était donné à
nos à nos interlocuteurs les promoteurs
et sous un mois une réponse et ça a
permis enfin en tout cas vous poserez la
question je pense à plusieurs promoteurs
quand même pour beaucoup d'entre eux de
limiter la la les grosses difficultés
qu'ils ont connu en 2023 au niveau de la
commercialisation qui était bloqué sur
les sur les particuliers c'est alors
c'est bien et en même temps on est à la
enfin je dirais à la limite de de ce qui
peut être fait là en tant que
amortisseur puisque c'est pas un plan
qui est reproductible en tant que tel
mais il était assez assez structurant
cette année euh je vais je vais pas en
en rajouter trop mais peut-être
illustrer deux points qui ont été dits
tout à l'heure il y a besoin de
construire on en est convaincu euh et
vraiment je sais que vous avez vu
plusieurs chercheurs mais c'est vrai que
il y a pas que la croissance
démographique elle compte mais il y a
aussi les besoins de renouvellement du
parc il y a aussi le desserrement des
ménages
l'augmentation des divorces des euh des
familles monoparentales euh aussi
l'évolution de la part des logements qui
est occupé à titre principal versus bah
tout ce qui va être logement résidence
secondaire mais aussi Airbnb donc là
aussi ce taux de résidence principal
c'est un un facteur à prendre en compte
et puis ce qu'on appelle la fluidité du
marché c'est-à-dire les fameux logements
vacants certes ils existent mais ils
sont pas dans les lieux où il y a ce
besoin de de construction donc donc
c'est donc et et c'est vrai que tout
cumulé enfin nous nos estimations euh
c'est celle de beaucoup des
professionnels c'est que il faudrait
450000 permis chaque année pour pouvoir
répondre à la demande et on en est
vraiment loin puisqu'on est plutôt en
baisse et donc le système aussi se fige
Philippe a parlé de parcours résidentiel
mais aussi enfin l'ensemble des les
présidents aussi on ont parlé euh le
taux de rotation dans notre parc Action
Logement immobilier mais c'est la même
que le parc HLM était de 8 % en 2019 il
est tombé à 6,9 % en 2023 donc on a
perdu au niveau national 1,1 point de
taux de rotation euh donc ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que c'est 60000
logements à l'échelle du parc HLM qui ne
sont pas juste reproposés à la location
puisque ça tourne moins les les
personnes restent plus longtemps dans
leur logement il y a une sorte
d'attentisme mais parce que on narrive
pas à accéder à la propriété donc on va
rester plus longtemps et en
Île-de-France le taux de rotation dans
nos filiales est de 4 3 % donc vous
voyez la libération se fait même plus
que 25 ans quoi c'est 25 ans avant de
tourner donc ça ça pose un un vrai sujet
ça c'est les chiffres du parc social le
parc intermédiaire aussi on le voit se
voilà se rétrécir la taille du parc
intermédiaire aussi ou du parc privé du
fait des des obligations qui ont été
rappelé tout à l'heure qui vont venir
sur les propriétaires qui n'arriveront
peut-être pas à les rénover donc c'est
c'est un c'est un sujet là aussi à
prendre en compte au regard de la
construction qui baisse et à côté de ça
on a moins on a moins d'offres sur le
marché donc là ça pose une question que
je vais vous poser parce que j'ai je
connais ma réponse mais c'est la mienne
c'est ça fait 15 ans qu'on gère des fils
d'attente effectivement sur
l'attribution des logements sociaux avec
un nombre d'inscrits qui augmente euh et
et là c'est vrai que nous on tire un peu
la sonnette d'alarme en disant il faut
que les travailleurs puissent aussi être
prioritaire dans ces attributions
puisqu'on en a de finalement on a de
moins en moins aussi de de L mis sur le
marché et c'est vrai que c'est on est
les on est un peu précurseur avec le
fait de mettre en ligne nos logements
pour les salariés et l'envers du décor
c'est que on a on a plus de 700000
inscrits aujourd'hui sur notre
plateforme donc c'est c'est énorme
nombreux entre eux sont des salariés
d'entreprise qui vont postuler une fois
deux fois trois fois et nous évidemment
on a aussi nos propres priorités
notamment ce que disait Philippe on va
mettre en priorité bah des salariés qui
n'ont pas de loge qui sont prioritaires
qui sont reconnus droit au logement
opposable ces publics là c'est 31 % de
nos attributions c'estàd quasiment un
logement sur trois qu'action logement va
attribuer c'est pour des publics qui
sont vraiment ultra prioritaires et donc
il y a il y a un vrai sujet de
priorisation de voilà de ces
travailleurs aujourd'hui dans cette
gestion en tout cas à court terme des
des fils d'attente et et l'autre point
c'est effectivement comment on développe
des solutions logement et et là c'est
des voilà c'est de l'ordre et ça répond
à vos questions au départ euh par
exemple sur la mobilité ben on on est en
train de développer de plus en plus de
solutions qui sont des des logements où
les personnes vont pour arriver il
rester un an renouvelable une fois et le
temps de s'installer dans la région et
donc ça ça donne des solution un peu
concrètes aux entreprises et là une
entreprise qui a des des problématiques
soit de croissance soit de vraiment
d'attractivité effectivement il y a
beaucoup de projets qui naissent que ce
soit en Bretagne en Vendé avec des
partarten ariat locaux pour réussir à
mettre en place cette offre qui est plus
fluide qui avec une gestion je dirais un
petit peu différente de la gestion des
logements sociaux et qui permet cette
fluidité et on a espoir et on espère en
tout cas que la mesure dans la loi de
finance de résidence intermédiaire donc
de mettre du statut intermédiaire sur
des résidences qui sont gérées permettra
de développer davantage de résidence
dite mobilité on en a une première à
Montpellier là qui vient d'ouvrir et on
pense que c'est ce type d'habitat en
tout cas peut répondre vraiment à court
terme à cette à cette demande de de
fluidité qu'on a mais ça répond pas à la
question structurelle et donc celle-là
elle reste quand même je pense à à
traiter à traiter dans dans son ensemble
j'en termine avec encore des chiffres je
suis désolé mais c'est important on on
de vous le dire aussi euh Bruno a parlé
de la RLS Philippe également euh C euh
c'est vraiment au moment où la la charge
d'intérêt augmente pour les bailleurs
sociaux
une mesure qui est vraiment très
difficile et qui fait que nos finances
au niveau des de nos bailleurs mais
c'est le cas pour l'ensemble des
professions des bailleurs sociaux elle
elles deviennent enfin je dis pas ouais
très très de plus en plus contrainte
l'autofinancement il est divisé par 3 en
en en macro donc on n' pas encore les
comptes 2023 mais c'est à peu près
l'ordre de grandeur et la charge
d'intérêt pour nous elle est doublée et
donc ça c'est aussi lié au fait qu'on a
beaucoup produit donc on on assume de
produire mais on produit avec des taux
varable et donc c'est vrai que ça fait
des des charges importantes et et là
aussi ça interpelle quoi au moment où
les les taux augmente de de voir quelle
solution on peut trouver je sais qu'on a
déjà échangé sur ce sujet de de la RLS
mais il faudra sans doute passer par des
des mesures de neutralisation
complémentaires pour permettre le
réinvestissement des des bailleurs
sociaux V aajouter quelque chose
oui
on pourrait croire qu'on est au fond de
la piscine mais c'est pas
certain dans toutes les mauvaises
nouvelles et les chiffres calamiteux
qu'on qu'on vient de donner il y en a un
qui me fait encore plus peur que le
reste c'est que dans ce marasme absolu
on souhaite lancer une
décentralisation alors moi je va pas
repartir de cette audition sans vous en
avoir parlé parce que question ça peut
être extrêmement calamiteux parce que
j'ai pas bien compris si les
financements seraient au moins
identique à à au peu qui nous reste je
dis bien au peu qui nous reste euh
j'entends hein les 42 milliards pour le
logement c'est le plus gros en Europe
enfin sur les 42 milliards il y en a
déjà plus de la moitié ou au moins la
moitié qui partent aux apl donc c'est
pas tout à fait pour euh la le monde de
la construction et cetera et cetera et
si on allait un peu plus loin les droits
de mutation dans par les françoisin tout
à l'heure ils servent aujourd'hui en
très très grande partie à
payer toute tout l'aspect social des
départements et je vais pas rentrer dans
le détail parce que c'est pas le le lieu
mais je veux dire on contribue très
largement à à soutenir l'effort l'effort
du
pays alors moi j'ai j'ai plusieurs
inquiétudes un le financement et je
viens de l'exprimer très clairement de
je crois que dans ce pays beaucoup
confondent la décentralisation et la
déconcentration voilà donc le temps que
ça n'est pas extrêmement
clair je je je souhaiterais qu'on
attende une relance de de l'activité
pour pouvoir se pencher sur la question
tout en même temps c'est formidable mais
là je pense qu'on va se casser la gueule
il faut enfin moi je je suis très clair
sur le
sujet je je suis plutôt quelqu'un
de d'intellectuellement ouvert à la
nouveauté j'ai la chance et l'honneur de
présider le groupe peut-être le le plus
décentralisé de France en tout cas dans
la dans l'aspect sur la partie logement
c'est une certitude mais là je c hein
quand on est en pleine tempête euh
vouloir tout changer et et et notamment
en pané généralement ça se finit au fond
de l'eau donc là j'ai j'ai les pires
j'ai les pires craintes je rappelle là
aussi que si on décentralise même si on
y apporte un peu de financement et
cetera mais qu'on a plus d'ambition on
va on va empirer les choses
euh notre groupe c'est si on prend que
celui que je connais le mieux a et vous
le savez très bien toutes les trois une
politique ambieuse nationale et ensuite
elle est décentralisée puisque c'est une
organisation matricielle nous sommes sur
tous les
départements de pote à Pitre à à
mamouzou de Lille à Marseille donc on
est partout mais la ligne politique
l'ambition et la la la férocité à
réaliser il y en a qu'une elle se doit
d'être nationale et porté par tous et
ensuite on travaille sur les territoires
ça je l'ai pas encore entendu jeai j'ai
pas bien compris
et je pense que si dans cette crise on
rajoute une
décentralisation peut-être que certains
font des économies mais une chose est
sûre c'est que nous on va finir par se
casser la gueule donc donc ça euh c'est
c'était quand même un un sujet que je
voulais évoquer et et comme le tourne je
voulais quand même essayer de dire
les les les sujets ou les mesures sur
lesquelles je crois qu'on est un peu
près euh tous d'accord parce que c'est
important aussi de repartir avec un peu
de de de positivité euh ça a été dit
avec les mots de chacun mais je crois
que un
euh la création d'un vér statut de
bailleur privé fait l'unanimité
h donc là aussi faut pas croire que
c'est une une vieille idée ça jamais
existé non ça c'est disruptif et c'est
pas parce qu'on l'a dit 10 fois mais on
l'a jamais mis en place évidemment que c
une de nos demandes dans le CNR et
cetera et cetera mais c'est pas parce
qu'on l'a dit que que ça devient un
truc passé donc ça je pense que c'est
c'est l'un des trucs les plus importants
ENF cette création du du statut du
bailleur privé est essentiel de là aussi
je pense qu'on l'a tous dit la
neutralisation moi je dis pas
l'annulation je dis la
neutralisation de la réduction de loyer
de solidarité que nous on appelle RLS
est nécessaire au moins le temps que la
mécanique est aussi est grippé ça
permettra et on pourrait en plus cibler
cet argent de de façon extrêmement
précise au montage financier des
opérations de logement
abordable je dis plus intermédiaire
social abordable parce que tout ça pour
les Français c'est incompréhensible lui
il est dans un logement social l'autre
il est dans un logement intermédiaire
non logement abordable pour tous on
neutralise la RLS ensuite moi dans ce
que j'ai
noté
c'est évidemment l'élargissement
peut-être de cette TVA on en a parlé 10
fois Dominique mais on on l'a jamais on
na jamais obtenu gain de cause donc la
TVA 55 pour l'ensemble
des des investissement ultra simple
ultra efficace en terme de d'efficience
évidemment on souhaite tous la maîtrise
du foncier je crois que ça a été là
aussi hein dit dit par tout le monde
alors il y a plusieurs méthodolog
vous savez que nous au MF on n'est pas
pour l'encadrement de tout euh et et que
voilà on souhaite
pas que on souhaite pas l'encadrement
total du du foncier mais quand on voit
quelques collectivités de temps en temps
qui font des bénéfices énormes sur du
foncier qui nous revendent quand je dis
nous là côté bailleur peut-être qu'on
pourrait un peu ou les CCII ou truc
peut-être qu'on pourrait un peu
canaliser euh tout ça et regarder si
l'offre si on faisait si on avait par
exemple un plan national de l'ensemble
du
foncier public parap public et privé mis
mis en vente ou pouvant être mis à la
vente peut-être que là aussi ça
permettrait
d'avoir d'avoir un prix de foncier un
peu plus un peu plus sobre euh ensuite
on l'a dit l'accélération de la mise en
œuvre effective des mesures fiscales
dégressives euh sur le foncier et la
détention des
biens je vois pas pourquoi là on fait
rien ça coûte rien et ça peut rapporter
gros comme dirait l'autre donc on on
pourrait le faire
euh les taux Bernard en parlait
euh je pense que le taux d'usure faut
continuer à le regarder de très près à
le serrer tous les mois je crois que ça
a été une demande de de tous à l'époque
où où ça a flambé moi je vois pas
d'autre solution que de continuer à
regarder tous les mois ce taux d'usure
et et de voir comment on peut le on peut
le contraindre et puis enfin et là aussi
ça a été dit à mainte reprise le prêt à
taux zéro pourquoi on veut le
conditionner à ceci cela faisant un truc
super simple on fait un un un prê à taux
zéro pour les Français modestes il
suffit de caper un peu le le sujet on
regarde comment on peut faire et puis on
permet aux Français moyens comme on dit
de réaliser le rêve de sa vie d'acheter
ce fameux pavillon avec bout de jardin
je sais que ça peut ne plus être à la
mode et cetera et cetera sauf sauf que
ça reste le rêve de la plupart des
Français et de temps en temps on
pourrait les écouter les
entendre merci beaucoup et bien écoutez
merci beaucoup aux uns aux autres et aux
unes aux autres pour ces éléments très
très précis je vais laisser la parole à
à à mes deux corapporteurs alors c'est
vrai que vous entendre on se
dit qu'est-ce qui va pouvoir faire
changer le logiciel du gouvernement
aujourd'hui force de constater que les
uns et les autres on aura essayé
beaucoup de choses on a tiré la sonnette
d'alarme sur voilà de nombreux points et
on voit bien que le discours n'a à aucun
moment un temps soit peu évolué
c'est-à-dire qu'on reste toujours sur le
même discours cours la politique du
logement elle coûte cher sans dire
qu'elle rapporte énormément euh et le
logement c'est une rente grosso modo
c'est ça au quoi on assiste depuis 2017
et peut-être encore plus depuis 2022
donc voilà qu qu'est-ce que est-ce qu'il
faut qu'on fasse alors la mobilisation
vous l'avez faite parce qu'aujourd'hui
encore plus concrètement et de façon
pragmatique avec l'Alliance pour le
logement où là encore tous les acteurs
du logement je veux dire on peut pas
nous quand on a fait une table ronde on
allait de la fondation abépierre jusqu'à
la Fédération du bâtiment et je veux
dire et même christophe Robert qui était
là et d'ici un jour je pensais me
retrouver à une à une table ronde où on
fasse tous d'abord le même constat où on
on on annonce quand même un certain
nombre de mesures qui sont relativement
consensuelles après il y a des il y a
des différences qui existeront toujours
mais quand même sur le gros et pour
autant je veux dire il y a y a il y a
rien qui se passe et les derniers
discours qu'on end du ministre du
Logement c'était encore de tout renvoyer
effectivement à cette grande loi sur le
logement dès qu'on on posait un problème
où on émettait que ce soit Airbnb que ce
soit la fiscalité que ce soit bien
évidemment le foncier la
décentralisation puisque nous a dit
décentralisation ça ne sera qu'un volet
mais il y aura une politique de
décentralisation qui va tout régler et
puis le ministre qui se gargaris de dire
oui oui mais il faut construire là où
sont les besoins parce que ça il l'a dit
plusieurs fois là où sont les besoin
mais aujourd'hui est-ce que ça a encore
du sens de toute façon de dire qu'il y a
des territoires qui sont tendus d'autres
qui sont détendus euh à mon sens plus du
tout je veux dire pourquoi on
assignerait à résidence des gens qui
sont dans les territoires dit plus
détendus et qui n'auraient pas la
possibilité eux parce qu'on ne ferait
pas l'effort de construction y compris
chez eux avec maintenant les injonctions
contradictoires d'Usan enfin et cetera
donc simplement voilà qu'est-ce quel
qu'est-ce qu'elle peut être la pour vous
le déclencheur qui fasse que peut-être
d'ici la fin de ce mandat on arrive les
uns et les autres à se dire que le
discours politique de
l'exécutif va enfin changer ou va enfin
entendre un temps soit peu ce que nous
disons tous parce que il reste peu de
temps et je crois pas que le logiciel
pour l'heure va changer alors je ne sais
pas qui sera le prochain ministre du
Logement mais de toute façon sera pas un
ministre du Logement de plein exercice
de toute façon il aura pas négocié
grand-chose et donc il aura aucune marge
de manœuvre et on sera encore sous la
coupe de Bery donc voilà c'est c'était
juste et après je laisserai mais mes
collègues voilà poser peut-être des
questions plus précises mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on est un petit peu
découragé des abuser parce qu'on se dit
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire les uns et
les autres pour qu'enfin bah ce que vous
dites qui semble qui juste frappé au
coin du bon sens soit enfin entendu même
si c'est pas totalement entendu mais
qu'on voit qu'il y a voilà un changement
de logiciel et PE peut-être nous donner
aussi deses perspectives quand est-ce
qu'on comprendra que la politique du du
logement elle s'inscrit dans le temps
long dans le temps long et vous disiez
si on n pas de stabilité si on a pas de
visibilité voilà on fera quelques
mesurettes mais on ça conduira jamais à
véritablement et on sait qu'on est
pessimiste 2024 mais vous le disiez 2025
et 2026 avec des élections municipales
quoi donc on est rentré dans un tunnel
quand même il faut bien le reconnaître
monsieur àel oui madame la Présidente si
vous permettez en fait je pense que dès
le départ on est parti sur des mauvaises
pistes hein comme je vous disais
bon voilà inscrire les filles ben c'est
c'est tout simplement un acte qui est
posé je presque philosophique de se dire
bah tout ce qui est immobilier ne bouge
pas donc ça ne favorise pas entre
guillemets l'économie ça ne nourrit pas
l'économie et cetera donc on est déjà
parti sur une très mauvaise piste ça
c'est un premier constat ensuite il y a
un deuxième constat qui lui tout à fait
factuel c'est-à-dire que le coût du
logement n'a cessé d'augmenter que ça
soit celui de la construction
ou que ce soit celui dans les zones
tendues bien de du prix de d'accession
et donc aujourd'hui quand vous avez
quand même un très beau salaire sur
Paris par exemple et bien devenir
propriétaire par le fruit de son propre
travail est devenu inaccessible et ça
c'est désespérant faut bien le faut bien
le reconnaître donc l'idée de se dire il
faut que le marché atterrisse et se se
régule bah sur le fond oui ça peut
s'entendre mais le problème c'est qu'on
est parti sur une fausse piste parce que
il y a pas de bullle immobilière je le
répète voilà et et et dans tout cela on
connaît depuis très longtemps tous les
mots qui nous ont amené là à savoir
effectivement la surréglementation hein
l'évolution normative qui n'a cessé
entre guillemets d'augmenter on demande
aussi et il faut bien faut bien
l'admettre que même dans les logements
sociaux le niveau entre guillemets de
qualité des logements est tout à fait
exceptionnel aujourd'hui dans notre pays
tout ce qu'on construit en UF c'est
quand même c'est c'est formidable tant
mieux mais c'est un coup voilà et puis
l'élément déclencheur et ben c'est
efftivement d'un seul coup l'explosion
des taux et là pouf tout remonte à la
surface et le grand dilemme c'est qu'on
a cru alors pas nous bien évidemment pas
nous les professionnels mais on a cru
que le marché de la rénovation
énergétique allait absorber tous les
actifs entre guillemets qui ne seraient
plus sur le marché de la construction
parce que là il y a a un volume énorme
de travaux ce qui est vrai et c'est une
bonne nouvelle je le répète il y a pas
de bulle donc le jour où on va réaligner
les les planètes ça va repartir alors
qu'est-ce qui peut maintenant
effectivement déclencher mais déjà
l'économie est en train de patiner voilà
et que lorsqu'on voit que dans
l'industrie entre guillemets dans le
secteur de la construction c'est un peu
plus de 130000 destructions d'emplois
qui sont attendus en 2024 là ça va
commencer entre guillemets à faire
réagir en tout cas je je le suppose hein
deuxièmement l'impact de la construction
est phénoménal sur l'ensemble de
l'économie
voilà troisièmement non seulement sur
l'ensemble de l'économie du secteur
marchand mais aussi sur on l'a dit sur
ce qui alimente énormément la solidarité
du pays voilà hein donc voilà entre
guillemets
entre un secteur de la construction qui
est en panne et qui va générer de la
druction emploi euh si on réinjecte on
va dire des moyens ou si on oriente
l'épaggne qui existe et ça aussi c'est
une bonne nouvelle hein les Français
c'est 18 % d'Épagne c'est ass c'est un
tau très élevé hein si on arrive à
réorienter les épargne vers la
construction vers la rénovation c'est de
l'économie non délocalisable voilà ce
seront des entreprises françaises avec
des salariés salariés par les
entreprises françaises hein donc il y a
un levier formidable pour que ça
redécolle la mauvaise nouvelle c'est que
c'est un secteur avec beaucoup d'inertie
je l'ai dit en préambule c'està dire
qu'en 2024 quoi qu'on fasse ça va être
une année quand même très compliquée
voilà mais bon on a entre guillemets des
leviers qu'on connaît pour pour que ça
reparte on peut faire des choses
heureusement d'ailleurs
oui merci à vous tous de de vous exposer
et puis de ce que vous nous apportez
aussi pour cette mission euh oui moi je
je rajouterai ce que tu disais Dominique
sur le fait que le l'exécutif ne veut
pas de construction parce qu'il y a
aussi ce problème de la bétonnisation
pour lui logement c'est béton voilà donc
on veut plus bétonner donc on voilà
voilà il y a aussi ça mais bon moi je
suis contente aussi de ce que tous vous
avez dit on a besoin de construire on a
besoin de construire pour RP répondre à
la demande sociale mais aussi pour
répondre à la demande de notre économie
c'est-à-dire effectivement vous venez de
le dire quand quand le quand la
construction s'arrête c'est toute une
économie et au-delà de de la filière du
bâtiment qui qui ne va pas bien donc bon
voilà moi je pense que ça peut faire
effectivement c'est un des sujets qui
peut faire réagir moi j'avais une des
questions sur le le logement des
salariés c'est vrai que ce logement des
salariés c'est une actualité majeure
dans nos territoires dans tous nos
territoires même les plus reculés euh
sentraîne d'autres questions vous l'avez
dit aussi sur la mobilité profession
professionnelle qui par manque de
logement devient de plus en plus
difficile mais aussi sur la question du
coût induit dans les déplacements pour
aller que du domicile au lieu de travail
qui sont du coup de plus en plus
éloignés et souvent et particulièrement
dans les zones où le logement est cher
et c'est un sujet cela particulièrement
euh comment dire prégant dans les zones
tendues et touristiques et ce qui
m'amène à la question très particulière
du logement des saisonniers mais aussi
des salariés de ces stations
touristiques parce que les les deux sont
impactés donc moi je voudrais savoir si
on a vraiment des chiffres fiables et
les
territorialisés du du manque de logement
dans les euh dans les euh de
particulièrement pour les saisonniers
dans les zones touristiques si on a
vraiment des chiffres fiable là-dessus
si vous avez vous des propositions très
particulières euh pour pour des les
saisonniers qui ont en fait besoin d'un
logement pour un temps très réduit don
la question de ce qu'on fait de parce
que c'est très rare qui est les doubles
saison c'est-à-dire qu'ils puissent
avoir des des logements toute l'année en
très souvent il leur faut un logement
pour une saison d'été un logement pour
une saison d'hiver ou d'autres les
saisons sont souvent voilà et puis ce
que vous avez évoquer le la concurrence
avec les meublés de tourisme et et ce
cette question aussi du bail Mobil
c'est-à-dire queon avait trouvé dans je
sais plus quelle loi ce fait que la loi
voilà voilà ce ce bail mobilité et puis
la question de l'accession à la de
l'accession à la propriété par des
entreprises avec l'achat de logement
pour loger les salariés bon j'ai j'ai
bien vu compris Bruno que vous n'étiez
pas tout à fait de ça mais on a quand
même des exemples euh je sais que la
compagnes des Alpes rachète des
ensembles de de des ensembles
d'immeubles meubl touristiques en
gardant des logements pour ses
saisonniers et ses salariés euh je sais
par exemple chez moi aussi euh là c'est
une commune la mairie de de cotteré où
il y a 90 % de résidences secondaires et
de meublé de tourisme rachète un hôtel
et le rénve pour faire des logements
pour les saisonniers et puis construit
aussi des logements en BRS pour avec le
pH pour le de l'accession sociale à la à
la au salariés pour les jeunes salariés
de la commune et on a ces exemples là
aussi de d'entreprises qui avaient avant
EDF la CNCF les enseignants vous l'avez
dit les serv les enseignants c'est un
modèle bien évidemment qui révolue et
justement il y a tous ces tous ces
bâtiments aussi qui sont sur mais qui
sont très obsolètes en terme de
d'accueil mais qui sont aussi je vois
chez moi par exemple DF a des logements
qui sont vacants et qu'il qui pourrai
peut-être être être utilisés aussi mais
il faut les rénover et ça un coût aussi
voilà
alors concernant les concernant les
saisonniers oui on a des chiffres on
pour vous les faire passer Nadia vous à
tout ça avec avec grande
précision je vais vous donner peut-être
l'exemple plus frappant que l'on a eu à
à traiter il y a depuis depuis quelques
années nous avons été appelés par
Jean-Christophe Angelini je sais pas si
vous voyez qui c'est c'est le maire de
porovcot il a un sujet de saisonnier
il a un petit sujet de
saisonnier si mes chiffres si ma mémoire
est bonne et vous m'excuserez peut-être
à dispr en gros il y a
4800 et
quelques foyers à porovc il y a
5000 caravanes
et et et mobilome et cetera posé dans
des champs dans des champs même pas sur
on parle même plus que de camping ou de
choses posé dans dans des champs
alimenté avec des tuyaux d'eau et cetera
et cetera tellement la la problématique
des des saisonniers est importante et
puis aujourd'hui saisonnier ça veut plus
rien dire ce qui nous a expliqué avec
beaucoup de passions c'est que sur des
zones comme la sienne la saison c'est 10
mois sur 12 donc les gens sont là
quasiment à l'année et on ne trouve
aucune
solution donc il fait appel à une
structure comme Action Logement pour
avancer et avancer vite parce qu'il a un
peu près tout essayé alors je dis pas
que le le le maire qui achète l'ancien
Formule 1 hôtel Formule 1 il arrive à
refaire de trois logements mais c'est
pas quelque chose
d'industrialisable sincèrement le le
logement de nos concitoyens est une
question d'expert est une question de
professionnel on doit de de façon
générale he et pas exclusivement pour
Action Logement on doit
professionnaliser la gestion locative en
France on doit on doit professionnaliser
continuer à structurer les les bailleurs
sociaux et les bailleurs de façon
générale on on doit être capable
aujourd'hui de faire des des
propositions fortes euh pour là aussi
être proactif et ne pas attendre demain
matin la nouvelle loi je sais pas quoi
qui dira c'est pas 12000 c'est 17000 ou
50000 ou 100000 on doit travailler
ensemble pour trouver des meilleures
solutions on on doit continuer à à
discuter pour territoire par territoire
aujourd'hui on sait il y a
1200 bassins d'emploi en France qui ont
besoin de logements sociaux je je
partage complètement ce que dominiic
estri Sasson disait tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui c'est mort de dire c'est
tendu c'est détendu et cetera et cetera
euh je peux vous citer plein d'exemples
la Meuse par exemple vous avez des
territoires qui sont ultra tendus à
tuonville quand j'étais gamin une maison
ne valait rien et aujourd'hui avec la
proximité du
Luxembourg on atteint des prix de
fonciers et des prix de de maisons qui
sont complètement dingues le pays est
inaccessible donc on on a plein
d'endroits où aujourd'hui on ne peut
plus loger les gens donc toutes ces
questions doivent être abordées les unes
derrière les autres mais est-ce qu'il y
a une vraie raison de moins bien traiter
les saisonniers que de traiter nos
salariés
entre
guillemets classique c'est on on a
racheté une résidence de vacances à
Bandol vous voz Bandole et donc on est
capable de faire des choses il faut
juste
que la collectivité
ou l'entreprise vienent nous voir voit
sa fédération
son son organisation patronale où nous
appelle en direct pour qu'on trouve
ensemble les solutions donc on a encore
de la culturation à faire on a encore
des des des choses à à à faire connaître
ensuite
euh vous plutôt que des entreprises
rachèt plutôt que des entreprises
rachètent des des des des des logements
c'est plutôt passer par un intermédiaire
un professionnel qui pourrait qui peut
voilà être g en gestion on le fait
beaucoup on le fait déjà beaucoup et on
doit continuer ensemble à le faire
savoir et et et à le faire connaître j'
une question à poser par rapport à
action logement sur c'est 50000
logements par an construit Action
Logement c'est on en a construit 50000
là on va essayer d'être sur un train à 4
quel est le pourcentage qui reste
affecté au salariés 50 % et on est au
taquet de ce qu'on est capable de faire
50 % on peut pas aller au-delà il y a
tout ce qu' on a dit tout à l'heure le
quota préfectoral la priorité de la
priorité du du truc les dalallos enfin
voilà juste quand même il y a deux
volets hein il y a des logements qu'on
produit avec avec nos filiales et Action
Logement service finance des logements à
tous les bailleurs sociaux donc chaque
année en fait on achète des droit de
réservation et en 2023 c'est 100000
droits qu'on a acheté aussi bien auprès
des filiales d'Ali que des Offices
Publics donc en fait on a un volant de
réservation pour les salariés pardon qui
est plus large que nos seuls notre seule
production enfin c'est important de de
le de le dire et et peut-être juste pour
compléter en plus Fran soit dans le lli
on on peut mettre 100 %
de dans sur l'intermédiaire donc on peut
mettre 100 % de salariés mais si je peux
me permettre de de faire un lien parce
qu'il y en a évidemment un entre vous
deux entre vos deux questions
euh son construction et je crois que
c'est François qui le disait on va
mettre
malheureusement en difficulté 120000
salariés actuels 125000 enfin voilà ça
ça va être à peu près ce spectre donc
sans cette filière on n'atteindra pas le
plein emploi mais sans logement on ne
réindustrialisera pas la France et ces
deux clés sont peut-être une partie ou
une grande partie de la réponse à la
question comment pouvons-nous faire
c'est ça qu'il faut marteler s'il y a
pas de logement il y a pas de
réindustrialisation on voit bien que le
Président de la République appelle la la
réindustrialisation de ses vœux
quasiment au quotidien et le le retour
au plein emploi mais pour ça il faut se
donner les moyens et et c'est ça que
l'on c'est ça que l'on attend ce fameux
terreot pour que l'on puisse tous
travailler dans dans les meilleures
conditions ce qui est valable pour les
saisonniers valable pour les autres ce
qui est valable pour les autres est
valable pour les saisonniers chez nous
en tout cas on les traite de la même
façon et on a des vraies réponses et on
va sur les cas extrêmes Porto VO c'est
un cas extrême mais on peut par parler
de Cannes de Nice de Biaritz aujourd'hui
où on fait du BRS à Biaritz à 70 bornes
de Biaritz 70 km
euh on on voit passer les cas profession
serveuse en
hôtellerie caissère et cetera et cetera
est-ce que c'est durable est-ce que
c'est vraiment rendre service je sais
pas une chose est sûre c'est que les
deux trois petites cacahuètes que qu'on
nous a jeté elles ne suffiront pas à
combler le manque de logement et en tout
cas à relancer la mécanique de de la
construction et et le dernier point on
voit bien que les choses évoluent vite
presque d'heure en heure quand j'entends
que on va
[Musique]
donner enfin on va donner on on on va
stopper l'augmentation du GNR pour les
agriculteurs j'adore les agriculteurs je
suis champenois je suis directement
touché mais les gens du TP et du
bâtiment ils mettent pas de GNR ils ont
pas les mêmes contraintes que les autres
les problématiques de simplification et
cetera je suis désolé je je profite de
de cette audition pour dire que là c'est
pareil on doit tous être traité de la
même façon c'est pas possible de faire
un bout du truc pour l'un et puis et
puis rien pour les autres on va finir
par avoir un vrai problème
sociétal merci Amel parce que leur
tourne merci madame la Présidente je
vais tout d'abord commencer par vous
remercier bien surt pour tous vos
apports et puis peut-être réagir déjà
sur une première chose que vous avez
évoqué monsieur langran et dans la
continuité de de ce qu'a évoqué madame
la Présidente il y a quand même vous
avez dit tout à l'heure que il aurait
été il est intéressant il serait
intéressant que nous partagions le même
constat mais je crois qu'on partage tous
en fait le même constat parce que vous
disiez que nous partagions pas pardon le
même diagnostic je reviens là-dessus
parce que je pense que vous aviez en
tête d'autres mais mais les
professionnels et et nous-même
d'ailleurs on partage je veux le dire
clairement le même diagnostic et puis la
même incompréhension je vais pas revenir
là-dessus sur l'inaction le manque de
réponse en tout cas face à la gravité de
la situation ça c'est la première chose
et puis appuyz aussi sur ce que vous
disez le côté assez effrayant de tout
cela et sur l'impact sur la justice
sociale et donc en effet le danger sur
la démocratie et vous avez eu raison de
le dire parce queon l'entend pas
toujours et c'est pour moi un vrai un
vrai problème euh si vous permettez
alors je vais être un petit peu je vais
le dire de façon un peu simpliste mais
pour pour essayer de d'aller vous titier
dans ce que j'ai entendu en fait dans
dans dans les
réponses je n'ai pas endu enfin j'ai
entendu beaucoup de réponses que nous de
solutions que nous connaissons un peu
parler de zéos on a parlé de voilà de
plusieurs d' RLS enfin voilà ce sont des
choses qui sont mises sur la table
depuis pas mal de temps mais compte tenu
du contexte économique sociale
géopolitique écologique que nous
connaissons dans lequel nous vivons
cette crise est-ce que pour vous et là
je vais pas aller dans le micro mais
plutôt dans le macro est-ce que ce n'est
pas le moment où jamais de penser
repenser et c'est un peu le thème
finalement de cette table ronde le lien
entre emploi et logement et de le faire
muter ce lien est-ce qu'il y'y a pas
peut-être nécessité aujourd'hui de le
penser aussi différemment puisque là
j'ai entendu des solutions finalement
dans le dans un périmètre existant mais
est-ce que ce n'est pas le moment aussi
peut-être de le penser différemment je
trouve un lien peut-être avec ma ma ma
question suivante
euh
c'est sur la la différenciation des
réponses à apporter là je parle pas de
décentralisation je suis assez d'accord
avec vous sur sur votre analyse monsieur
arcadipan nous avons des territoires
aujourd'hui qui sont dans une très belle
dynamique et tant mieux économique je
vais parler de ce que je connais bien la
région desveau de France d'unkererque
avec 12000 logements quand même attendus
sur sur 10 ans aujourd'hui quelle
solution pourquoi parce qu'on le sait
c'est un cercle vertueux ou vicieux tout
dépend comment on l'entend et donc il a
il a cette nécessité de répondre de
façon assez urgente à des réponses
est-ce que il va falloir penser des
réponses aussi différentes selon les
territoires selon les problématique tout
en sachant qu'il a des territoires je
pense par exemple à ce grand canal
senord sur lequel on aura besoin de
logement mais pas de logement peut-être
pérenes mais qui vont peut-être
accompagner alors c'est vraiment encore
encore une logique différente mais ma
question est simple hein c'est en simple
ma question précise c'est plutôt est-ce
que il y aura besoin d'apporter des
réponses et c'est le cas aujourd'hui en
fait he c'est le cas aujourd'hui mais
est-ce qu'on ne peut pas aller plus loin
euh sur sur ces problématiques qui sont
réelles parce que pénurie de logement et
puis difficultés à recruter euh on peut
nous je suis aussi conseil régional on
se questionne aussi beaucoup et on
apporte des solutions on œuvre à cela
bien sûr hein mais à la réussite
finalement de ce grand projet de
réindustrialisation bien sûr des haut
France mais surtout d'autres que
d'autres territoires connaissent et puis
dernière petite question mais très
courte parce que le temps tourne on a
parlé à plusieurs reprises de logement
social euh moi j'aurais aimé alors bien
bien sûr nous partageons le constat de
bien sûr de demandes qui ont
explosé est-ce que aujourd'hui le modèle
de logement social je vais rester très
vague volontairement dans ma
question pourra répondre finalement
problématique que nous connaissons
est-ce que il y a peut-être besoin de le
faire muter à tous les niveaux je
m'arrêterai là sur les questions j'en
avais d'autres mais le temps tourne
merci beaucoup
ouais en fait vous nous demandez
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour
renverser la
table
euh alors c'est cert on pourrait si nos
propositions a déterminer un nombre de
logements proportionnel au nombre
d'emplois hein donc l'inscription voilà
sur un bassin l'inscription de
développements dans le Plan Local
d'Urbanisme avec le un schéma de
cohérence territoriale par exemple ça
pourquoi pas bien sûr je pense que c'est
une question aujourd'hui qui est tout à
fait pertinente hein voilà il y a des
endroits bien évidemment où on sait vu
l'évolution économique il y aura des
besoins de logement puis d'autres où bah
c'est c'est moins le cas hein ou là
c'est pe-être de de la rénovation ce que
j'ai envie de dire c'est que la nature
AORE du vide c'est-à-dire que on voit
très bien partout en France que des
microprjets naissent c'est-à-dire que
quand des entreprises ne n'actionnent
pas entre guillemets l'outil Action
Logement et ben elles font hein c'estàd
que il y a des entreprises qui sont en
train de transformer une partie de leur
bureau en logement par exemple hein ou
des entreprises qui rénovent ou qui
construisent pour loger des apprentis ou
pour loger bah des salariés hein ou des
saisonniers alors la question il faut
que ces entreprises en aient les moyens
voilà elles n'ont pas toutes les moyens
surtout les plus petites hein
deuxièmement elles ne connaissent pas
tout entre guillemets le levier Action
Logement mais le besoin est tel que je
ne suis même pas sûr queaction logement
puisse répondre entre guillemets à tous
ces micro projets c'est compliqué et et
et ce qu'on aura peut-être ce qu'on
aurait peut-être besoin entre guillemets
effectivement à développer c'est de voir
comment au niveau d'un Massin d'emploi
ou d'un Masson de vie on peut mutualiser
toutes ces demandes d'entreprise il y a
quelques années mon entreprise cherch
l'État ire dans les de s nord de sè et
c'est un territoire qui est assez
dynamique en terme d'emploi qu'il reste
tant mieux he on s'était regroupé à une
onzaine à 11 entreprises locales pour
voir comment on pouvait loger nos
apprentis hein et il se trouvait qu'il y
avait un bâtiment qui était disponible
et qui appartenait à l'éducation
nationale un lycée public hein et bien
on a laissé tomber parce que entre le
moment où on a eu toute tout cette idée
de transformer ce bâtiment inoccupé par
l'Éducation nationale lycée pour en
faire des logements pour les apprentis
avant de d'arriver à trouver le levier
éducation nationale le bon l'accord des
responsables locaux à
l'époque les travaux de réhabilitation
parce que là aussi on est soumis aux
normes et donc le bâtiment n'était plus
du tout au normes et cetera et ben on a
fini par baisser les bras parce que
c'était hors de portée trop compliqué
voilà tu bête hein alors que c'était
disponible peut-être rapidement pour
répondre au aux trois questions donc le
le cadre de vie de nos salariés je crois
que toutes les toutes les études le le
prouvent nos salariés sont plutôt bien
dans dans les entreprises on l'a vu
pendant le télétravail je l'ai vu dans
mes propres entreprises le télétravail
c'était bien au début si on veut être
vraiment disruptif imaginez à la Google
laisser leurs salariés chez eux il y a
il y a pas de chef d'entreprise qui peut
être contre ça demain on paye plus les
loyers on laisse les gens chez eux et
cetera et cetera sauf que vous perdez la
fierté d'entreprise vous vous perdez le
l'aspect collaboratif des collaborateurs
et le plus important nos collaborateurs
n'en veulent pas vous enlevez
l'exception du mec qui dit bonjour à
personne et cetera et cetera les autres
je vous assure que boire le café le
matin avoir des nouvelles avoir du lien
social l'entreprise c'est aussi ça et
c'est aussi un sujet qui nous est cher à
tous c'est la mixité sociale qui est la
plus grosse machine à
intégrer que que l'entreprise il y en a
pas il y a pas plus grosse machine que
l'entreprise pour intégrer les les les
gens donc c'est bien le jeunisme le le
le le le côté disruptif et cetera et
cetera mais il faut qu'on garde quelques
piliers et peut-être que l'entreprise
fait partie fait partie de cela ensuite
sur le les les sujets des grands
chantiers vous avez parlé d'unkerer du
canal s Nord je connais d'unquer que
presque comme le fond de ma poche à
force d'y aller on y allit à peu près
avec tout le monde il y a encore un mois
et quelques j'y étais avec Madame borne
donc avec le ministre d'unkerer enfin on
y était tous donc
euh le Canal C Nord c'est un exemple
plus peut-être plus technique euh là
aussi on a des réponses nous y étions
avec Xavier Bertrand avec Carole Delga
on a vu les premiers coups de pelle
l'eau arrivé sur le sur le le début du
chantier et cetera chez Action Logement
on est très pro innovation et on a des
chantiers en route là aussi Nadia pourra
vous passer les éléments et et vous en
parler autant que vous
voudrez sur de la construction modulaire
on on est aujourd'hui euh à côté de
start-up qui euh font du béton bas
carbone euh de façon modulaire aussi du
bois on a des gros partenariats avec ces
entreprises euh des des boîtes qui
démarrent à qui on donne déjà deux ou 3
ans de commande pour que justement elles
aient la visibilité vous voyez nous on
fait pas que demander on on donne aussi
euh ce genre de choses et et là vous
avez raison
euh il y a des solutions qui existent on
doit les mettre en œuvre de là à
imaginer que tout le monde du bâtiment
se mette à travailler de façon
industrielle et cetera sincèrement j'y
crois pas ou en tout cas j'y crois peu
la France ne peut pas être le village
olympique vous vous voyez en terme de
qualité ça a été dit tout à l'heure le
le français aime la qualité de son
logement on a besoin d'acoustique on a
besoin de de
thmie tout tout ça fait que il faut faut
savoir tout faire il faut un peu de tout
et c'est beaucoup plus complexe que dire
on trouve un modèle on met en place une
grosse machine et puis demain matin on
coule des blocs de
béton tout fait et cetera et cetera ça
ne pourra ça ne pourra pas le
faire en tout cas de de
façon très importante et on pourra pas
gérer tout le pays avec ce type de de de
construction et le dernier sujet
c'était la mutation moi j'aiécris
mutation
de ah la mutation du logement social bah
je l'ai dit un peu dans mon propos il
faut qu'on continue à travailler sur la
professionnalisation la
structuration de nos métiers on a fait
une on a fait des
sacs dans la loi élan si j'ai bonne
mémoire beaucoup ne
fonctionnent pas ou pas beaucoup on ce
est plutôt abrité de la loi des 12000 je
crois que là aussi si on veut avancer
oui on
peut faire des choses en tout cas nous
avons des propositions à faire pour
continuer à à
structurer ce secteur qui de toute façon
n'a pas le choix nous étions vendredi
avec Bernard verker à l'assemblée
générale d'une de nos plus belles
filiales cette année son résultat est
divisé par 13 par 13 à la limite de la
perte une de nos plus belles filiales
donc voilà on l'a dit tout à l'heure je
vais pas revenir dessus les les
ponctions à la fois récurrentes et
ponctuelles sont tellement fortes que
les meilleurs d'entre nous arrivent à la
ligne de flottaison donc on devra faire
quelque chose si on veut pas que le
bateau coule
définitivement et bien merci beaucoup
euh on a voilà merci de ces échanges
très francs et très très précis
instructif euh on vous souhaite une
bonne journée si vous avez des éléments
plus factuels enfin n'hésitez pas à les
faire passer à notre administrateur mais
je crois qu'il y a directement le lien
qui s'établit très souvent entre Nadia
et et et Mathieu merci on vous souhaite
une bonne fin de journée merci de nous
avoir consacrer tout ce
temps merci à
vous
mais bon vous avez vu